for ukrainians facing 2023 still
defending a Russian invasion the end
can't come soon enough
I would really like this year to be over
says Oksana morozenko
finding Joy here isn't easy
it's New Years that it makes me feel sad
her mother chimes in
as Russian airstrikes once again fall on
Ukraine
President Vladimir zolenski said the
world will never forgive the terror
Ukraine said we'll never forgive Russia
a Moscow Russian President Vladimir
Putin drank a toast with soldiers and
gave up medals
his defiant defense minister claims
Russia's Victory like the new year is
inevitable while Ukraine's defense
minister released this video a letter to
Santa thanking the West for weapons and
asking for more I hope you don't mind
that we generously shared some of your
gifts with our deranged Northern
neighbor
behaved very badly this year
Russia and Ukraine did exchange
prisoners in time for the new year 82
Russians had 140 ukrainians seen here
and other soldiers many fighting since
February came home by train to Kiev for
New Year's we spokes teeth and really
close the atmosphere
just to be together yeah just us the
country's Collective hope
Tamara kovalova says Ukraine wants
Victory and peace
as it enters to culminating one full
year at War Charter Shea Global News